and for all y'all black lives matter who
ain't saying nothing well let me figure
out exactly what happened before I say
anything you I want to uh bring up
something that Andrew you you found this
video on Twitter you saw this and you
wrote succinct eloquent accurate so this
is video of NBA legendar star he's a
multiple time Allstar he actually
converted to Judaism later in life moved
to Israel he was teaching uh sorry he
was coaching one of the Israeli
basketball teams I'm not sure if he's
living in Israel at the moment but he
had a uh a nice little video on what's
going on and and relating it to BLM and
everything we're talking about I woke up
man this morning with some disturbing
news out of Israel that Hamas
kidnapping children putting them in
cages killing women killing the elderly
that's some
cowards that's cowardly and for all
y'all black lives matter who ain't
saying nothing well let me figure out
exactly what happened before I say
anything you figure out
what ain't never been cool to kidnap
kids and put them in cages ain't never
been cool to kill women and and elderly
never been no matter where you from what
you represent what tribe you for don't
matter Michael is it such a a sign of
the times that I'm getting more astute
political analysis and and forget like
I'm getting more like basic truth let's
say from Amari STM who I used to watch
play basketball then say pretty much
anyone on mainstream media and certainly
on Hamas TV which some people know as
MSNBC and and certainly from The New
York Times the editor of of which was or
one of the editors of which was was R
tweeting this defense of decolonization
meaning the kidnapping of kids and rape
and murder of civilians it it is a sign
of our times it's a sign of many times
but it's a sign of our times because
we're we're living in a time where our
Elite are extremely corrupt and ignorant
and stupid so during times such as that
uh Ordinary People are going to make a
lot more sense and uh it's it's during
times like that that that you see the
proof of Bill Buckley's quote from 60 70
years ago which was he would rather be
governed by the first 2,000 people in
the Boston phone book than the faculty
of Harvard College I mean just look
Harvard had 30 plus student
organizations signing a letter basically
defending Hamas so if you want sense
Harvard would be the last place to look
Andrew do you think there is a silver
lining here like the the the horror and
the barbarity and the medieval style
killings which we're still just finding
out about like it's just off the charts
that they may and the fact that they
intentionally wanted people to see it
right the the Nazis hid their stuff they
documented it because they thought they
were going to be the winners and they
wanted a record not because they wanted
the world to see uh but because of the
severity of this and the fact that
they've gone ahead and put this out on
social media and and even now are
threatening to you know kill some of the
uh some of the hostages and and air that
that it has woken up some people in a
way that maybe they wouldn't have been
woken up otherwise just us talking about
sanity kind of doesn't hit with
everybody yeah that's right I I hesitate
to call it a silver lining because while
good does often come out of evil the
evil doesn't go away and none of those
lives can be recovered and none of that
tragedy will be erased by any good that
comes out of it but yes I do think that
people looked at these things and saw
these things and suddenly thought wait a
minute wait a minute you can't
intellectualize this away that's why I
retweeted that stoom video because of
its Simplicity you know I thought I I
turn to a you know it really only takes
the slightest spark of human decency
flickering dimly inside you to look at
the things that we have seen and think
oh those are the bad guys I get that
those are the bad guys and anything else
is better than that because this is evil
so the fact that as Michael points out
30 plus in uh organ itions at Harvard
did not have enough human decency left
to spot that shows you that
intellectualization can take you right
through the truth into a very very dark
place